2 years ago Congress spent 7.5 billion
on electric vehicle Chargers how many
have been built one that's $7.5 billion
for this this story makes me want to
yell show me the money because where did
the money go seriously where did it go
there are so many stories like this
where government will spend billions on
projects with little or nothing to show
for them like the Pentagon which can
account for 220 billion in gear given to
contractors and they failed six audits
in a row or Biden's $42 billion
Broadband project even though more than
90% of Americans already have access to
high-speed internet the VA bought 10,000
iPhones for $8 million never used 8,500
of them and never forget 400 billion in
Co Aid was either wasted or stolen so
the next time the feds proposed to spend
a bunch of money on a big new shiny
stimulus project even if it sounds great
don't forget how government spending
projects really work